- I've been praying for
a butt for 26 years.
Finally, finally I got one.
(upbeat music)
- It was a common thing to be told,
"You're Cuban? 'Cause
you don't have a butt."
- Okay, cute face, all right.
Then they see the back, it's like, "Dang!"
That doesn't happen to me.
Guys would go, "Da, oh, never mind."
- People would always make comments like,
"Oh, she's so skinny. She's so bony.
"She has no booty."
- I don't care what I look like
other than feeling good on the inside.
- At first glance they look
like my grandma's bloomers.
But then there's this padding.
- I can see how through
clothing this could
feel like a booty.
- This is like a second bra.
- They're not cute.
- I have a butt.
Finally, I got one.
- Oh, snap.
It actually looks really natural.
- I don't look like Kim
Kardashian, I look like
a normal human, which is awesome.
- It just looks fake.
I look like I did one too many squats.
- I just want to, like dance, you know?
I just want to go to the club.
Like, where is the club at?
- Makes me want to do
my favorite Ciara move.
- It looks like I have
to really take a shit.
Like, oh my God, I gotta go!
- Good job, guys, whoever made that.
That was like (click). Looks good.
- There's another one?
I thought this was a jock strap.
- I guess these parts
cup underneath the butt?
- Koosh, koosh, koosh,
like I'm a transformer.
- First of all, my butt
looks like a hexagon.
- Did I do it wrong?
I think I did it wrong.
It's a permanent wedgie
too, which is so terrible.
There's like major strappage going on
and it looks like my ass
cheeks just got chiseled off.
- This still looks like
my butt, just lifted.
Which, I guess, makes sense.
I'm getting major panty line.
Well, what are you wearing this with?
- And it's skin in other
places, like weirdly.
- If you're gonna wear
something to make your body
look better and it's
gonna take you 10 minutes
and a little bit of sweat to get it on,
it better look damn good.
And this doesn't look damn good at all.
- My lung is over here
now because it's all been
pushed back.
- I just want to get out of this, please.
I can't breathe.
- I think it's okay if
people use butt enhancers.
If it's gonna enhance your
confidence along with your body,
I'm all for it.
- I mean, it's like (click) okay.
If you're really feeling
good about yourself,
sometimes that's not a bad thing.
- I already have a lot of
stuff to put on in the morning.
This Afro, alone, takes like
45 minutes to deal with,
so I really don't have time to search
for my morning butt pad.
- I like my little butt and I cannot lie.
(jazzy music)